Ramadan is considered the most venerated, blessed...
...and spiritually beneficial month of the Islamic year.
Prayers, fasting, charity and self-accountability...
...are especially stressed at this time.
Religious observances associated with Ramadan are kept throughout the month.
Fasting is prescribed daily for all able adult Muslims...
...during the whole month of Ramadan,...
...beginning with the sighting of the new moon.
During Ramadan in the Muslim world,...
...most restaurants are closed during the daylight hours.
Families get up early for Suhoor, a meal eaten before the sun rises.
After the sun sets, the fast is broken with the meal known as Iftar.
Iftar usually begins with dates and sweet drinks...
...that provide a quick energy boost.
Fasting serves many purposes.
While they are hungry and thirsty,...
...Muslims are reminded of the suffering of the poor.
Fasting is also an opportunity to practice self-control...
...and to cleanse the body and mind.
And in this most sacred month,...
...fasting helps Muslims feel the peace that comes from spiritual devotion,...
...as well as kinship with fellow believers.